[Music]
you're listening to
inside of you with michael rosenbaum hi
folks if you just joined me and your big
joel mchale fan you don't know who the
hell i am which is very possible i
appreciate you being here
i appreciate you giving me the chance
and hopefully after this episode uh
you'll listen to more of my episodes
that's what you hope
i really think this is a great episode
with joel mchale i'm not tooting my own
horn but
it was one of my favorites i felt
incredibly comfortable talking to him
and uh he was open about just about to
everything i asked
him would you say ryan yeah i would say
he's very comfortable
very comfortable he sent me some gin he
sent me like this gin that i guess
i don't know if they give him money or
whatever but a bottle of gin and glasses
and stuff like that it was really uh
nice
i meant that he was coming he laid on
the couch he laid on the couch so you
had to sit down because he's a a very
tall he's a muscular man he's a tallman
he is he's in great shape he looked
great i was uh
i was i wasn't shocked i was more
shocked at how bad i looked next to him
i believe yeah well he's still hosting
television you gotta look a certain way
yeah what are you saying i have to shave
i'm saying he has to be more prepared
for stuff
yeah are you saying that i have to get
back in shape to do that stuff i'm
saying you look great the way you want
i don't know if i believe that now i'm
in my head for the rest of the episode
way to go
uh hey guys if you really like the show
please subscribe write a review
uh if you watch on youtube you could
write a review you could also write a
review on apple
ryan tell them where they could
subscribe follow the podcast on twitter
at inside of you pod on twitter inside
of you podcast on instagram and facebook
youtube.com inside of you with michael
rose that's correct a big thanks to my
producing uh partner there bryce my
engineer and editor
ryan fantastic work guys i'm going to be
at the end of the show listen for it
but i'll tell you where i'm going to be
doing some conventions they're going to
be a lot of fun
and also where to zoom me if you want to
zoom me at sunspin.com and a bunch of
other things
after the podcast but let's just get
into this one this is
again one of my favorites and uh we talk
about everything we talk about uh
working with chevy chase and how after
chevy's departure how that affected him
and um
just life in general let's get inside
of joel mchale it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael
[Music]
rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you're like the henry winkler of younger
actors because
you you're likeable like everybody i've
never heard one bad thing oh joel mikael
i love joel mchale
oh i love joel mchale it's nice of you
to call me young
are you not young no i'm gonna be 50
this year i'll be 49 this year
welcome to our world well doesn't that
mean we have
my brother always says you're 49 so
you're well when i turn
40s like you know you're closer to 80
than zero
and i didn't like that so now i'm 40
i'll be 49. so
i mean like what's the average life
expectancy uh what does your producer
say
i believe and correct me if i'm wrong
it's 271.
just in case you want to talk through
your penis i just
aimed the monkey yeah that was weird
what is the penis going to say
yeah what would that be i don't know
what's the average um
yeah about 80. uh life-size 85-85
i would say it's probably late 70s isn't
it maybe it's 80 is it 80s
yeah i think it's close to 80 now i
think it went down with cove yeah now
it's popping back up again
yeah we do you remember where we met uh
the
first time no i mean i know where
we saw each other uh but was that where
we met
i thought we met maybe i don't know i
remember
we were testing for the community yes
and it was it was a network
test it was just me and you it was just
the two of us yeah and my agent kept
saying well it's just between you and
this guy joel mchale yeah and i remember
going in but i remember talking to you
and
my brother picked me up from the
audition and i said
he goes how'd you do i go i did great he
goes what do you think i go
no way i'm gonna go this guy walked in
there and he was just charming as [ __ ]
he was handsome he just he just
he just seemed smarter than me he was he
just
i'm telling you i think he got the role
i swear to god and then you got the role
i i just in fact i remember going i
don't even want the role now because
this guy
this is his role wow that is so my
experience was
oh i didn't get that that's how you felt
yeah i was like the handsomer smarter
more charming guy went
in no and i swear to you and then
after their so after i went in the
network was like
uh we're on the fence and then
i was put they put me on camera to
record the scene because i think i was
nervous and then i recorded the scene
they showed the network
the camera scene they went okay were you
nervous that second time it's like
it gets worse and worse doesn't it the
[ __ ] uh at that point
i think i had gone over the material so
much that um
i think i could have done it for anyone
like on five
oxy suspended over a bridge so uh
but i remember going like oh i have
literally by the way i've never
ever said this that this thing out loud
uh i've never like talked about like how
we were up for the role
oh wow yeah yeah i haven't either i
remember talking about it to some people
but
uh it was just one of those roles i
remember and i'm not being
you know nice and like humble about it i
just remember saying he's gonna get the
role i know he's gonna get the role
it just seemed if you and you watch the
show it just fits i'm more
kind of like you're dry rye you know you
have that certain personality that you
just kind of that leading man that all
the stuff comes at you
and you just bounce it off in a funny
way i think we're just a little
different
i might be too much and you you're just
it's like porridge oh i don't think
you're too much
i don't wh no i'm not putting myself
down completely
my listeners hate when i do that really
well yeah but i i mean it and i don't
try to think you know i said something
about being smart and they're like
stop saying you're not smart i'm like i
didn't say i'm not
smart i just i don't know it's better to
say you're not smart
and then then go i know exactly what i'm
talking about
right i 100 agree with you you become a
dick very fast
i think it's very good to approach
things going i don't know everything
about this
and so i'm going to approach it as i
don't know anything about this
and so yeah that's why i remember seeing
akira kosawa thank you
uh get his lifetime achievement oscar
and he was like
man i have so much to learn from these
young directors
wow and i was like that seems right
as opposed to the dickholes that are
like
well i know how it all works i can see
the entire thing folks
it's okay to think you're good at
something
but it's how you sort of present it to
the world like
there has to be some kind of you can't
just say yeah i'm [ __ ] great i
deserve this oscar
i'm awesome yeah thank you i deserve
this and you guys did the right thing
for once
thanks good night yes and it happens
every once in a while where someone does
get an oscar and then they give a speech
where you go
well that wasn't real um grateful
that just seemed like they expected it
and um
they agreed and even if you think that
you should be
like wow the group of people i'm up
against is bananas and i cannot believe
i'm standing up here
instead of like yeah first one
uh or yeah yeah well i'll tell you a
story i was uh
here's a double name drop for you i have
a game i play when i steve martin
go ahead well i've worked with him as
have i thank you i know you have
but when i name drop i dropped something
so i was at carrick
carrie fisher's house oh good one drop
and sharon stone was there dropped
another pen
okay and i ended up talking with sharon
stone
and someone else that wasn't as big as
sharon stone
and she because why name them that's a
big
list of people who is not as big as well
known as sharon stone no matter what
yeah
but sharon's so it was really bizarre
but she
kept i i'm not putting down i think
she's a terrific actress she's
very i'm sure very bright but she kept i
swear to god may i die if i'm lying this
is not just hearsay this is
one-on-one she talked about her iq and
how off the charts brilliant she was
oh and i remember going god if i said
that well first i would i could never
say that but she kept going on about it
and then other people were hearing this
and we're just kind of like oh
she's like yes the doc you know the you
know my
colleagues or whatever say that you're
absolutely brilliant off the charts with
your iq
and it was that it i'm speechless and
i would say the one time her iq was off
the charts was in good fellas because
that performance was
a masterpiece that said did you read the
thing that she put in her book
that she went in to for surgery for to
have
minor benign uh growths removed
and the surgeon decided while she was
under
to go ahead and give her breast implants
that is a real story that she
really told and i look it up
be go right out in her book that she was
getting some cysts removed that were
benign
right and the doctor thought you know
what sharon deserves better
or there was just some you know implants
lying there and he was like you know
what wow we're here
i know i didn't ask her and why am i
uh why am i put why am i enlarging
breasts here
in this clearly probably like a cancer
center that removes tumors or whatever
yeah
uh and i'm just gonna stick these in
because they're here and they go bad
i don't know and then there was a thing
she said about basic instinct which was
she and this story is now pretty old
because it was in rosie o'donnell's
uh stand-up act but it was a story that
she told that she
did she was unaware of the shot and
basic instinct where she
unfold you know where she uncurls her
legs and pulls him back over she would
she thought that was they were just
doing a test shot it was such a bizarre
she was like i
i was unaware they were doing that and
then of course rosie o'donnell in her
brilliant stand-up said like you have to
light
the [ __ ] and it was like you have to
get a uh
like a arrange for focus on the [ __ ] he
she kept saying that
it was such a funny routine what was it
what was it like also the director goes
hey so you did this thing what did i do
you crossed your legs one over the other
and back and forth and it was just like
your legs were spread and we could you
know we could see
sort of like you know that uh so we were
thinking about using that
what right no right excuse possibly and
she's like
listen as you know in rehearsals with
short skirts i never wear underwear
but when we shoot i put the underwear on
that's how it works it was such a weird
thing to like those stories are like of
all the
just say look i did that i wasn't
comfortable but i said go ahead and do
it
and yeah you have bass no one was asking
her don't
and then you could like break you so you
had to and then i was what kind of
there's a disconnect
yeah there's there's something that's
what i said so did you ask her about
quantum physics or something so you're
like well let's talk about radical
trajectory if you want to get down to it
funny you said i'm a harvard grad i have
a law degree and i'd love to get into
this with you
yeah when you look at someone like uh
what's his name uh jeannie buss's dad
jerry jerry who was literally a rocket
scientist
teacher yeah oh yeah doctors designed
parts for a rocket and then decided you
know it's a smart move
buying an nba basketball team that that
smart
that's super smart and at no point have
you heard that guy
skull like just want to let you know i'm
like off the charts smart and no one
no one was questioning it no one was no
no no one uh it's really weird you know
what happened later that night and i'll
get off the sharon stone thing
somebody scored with one of the top 50
bachelors according to people magazine
folks he's looking at top 50 bachelors
from i think 2004
and it was me top 50 bachelors of people
and he's uh
i'd say it's a jab that is not a jab
that's
a a ribbing and a ribbon and a
compliment when you think about it
an acknowledgement yeah thank you look
were you ever the top 50 people well my
wife would have been
seriously pissed if i was one of the top
50 bachelors oh yes have
what the hell we're married uh i have
been in the sexiest man alive
epis uh episodes uh issues a couple of
times
wow but i think that's what proved that
i wasn't
i don't think because the photos weren't
i weren't you were embarrassed
yeah it was all just below the waist
stuff what
no i'm kidding yeah uh i was like
does that work i was like i think
there's better photos that's how i
always look at it
uh it's like when yeah it's i always i
always start
going well you know what i could have
done better in that photo
weirdo i could have done better than
that photo maybe the photographer could
have chosen better
it's like i'm blaming the accompanist
when i'm trying to do a singing audition
like if you did it right then i would
have
then i would have been great you know
you say that you couldn't take good
pictures but look at your physique and i
know dax talked about this this isn't a
picture this is
this is just and i like you being
comfortable and you know ryan has to
resort to sitting on a uh
on a stool but that's real i didn't know
the setup so now i'm
no you're a tall guy you need to relax
you need a lounge how tall are you
thank you for asking i'm 7-1 you were a
liar
6-4 6-4 yes how long have you been 6'4
uh since i was a senior in high school
you just blossomed
bloomed uh yeah my dad entered high
school
and he fought he boxed in
below 100 pounds when he entered high
school
and when he got out of high school he
was six one
uh he was tiny person that's what i was
oh well there you go
i was five foot two i think as a
freshman
i graduated five four and then my year
in between college and high school i
jumped up to six feet wow that's why i
have back problems
but that's that's probably why what part
of your back lower back
no i can fix that i don't think you kind
of had seven spine surgeries
well you're right i can't i was going to
say
if it's just always been a chronic thing
then i can give you a number of exercise
because i had terrible lower back
problems
okay well i still want these exercises
because maybe it will help
all right so i would always blow my back
out my lower back
and i would be i just have to lie down
for like two days and i was like i'm an
old man
this is now 20 years ago right and then
i had kids who you have to pick up all
the time and my back was going out
and then i did a movie in 2013 thank you
deliver us from evil
thanks a lot for remembering guys i do
remember that thank you i'm a horror fan
oh god bless
uh and then this i my back was spasming
and i'm like i don't know how i'm gonna
do this action stuff and then this tiny
little trainer named ali grits
uh on the west side said i'm gonna fix
your back in about uh
two weeks and i was like okay and then
it was deadlifts i started with barely
even the bar
and i couldn't hardly do it she's like
we're doing it every day and then
in about four days like five days i was
like i'm a young man again
i was like they're serious and now i
have always had them in my routine
and i worked up to like now i can do
tons of weight and i
whenever i do it i'm like all right it's
this part of your body that people
always ignore
it because lift with your legs lift with
your legs be careful and then all of a
sudden you
treat the lower back as a china shop and
you don't ever
use those muscles and you should if you
isolate the muscles and do it safely
it's a new lease on life so deadlifts
that's when you kind of like you have
the bar when
you kind of bend your knees you pick it
up you barely bend your knees you know
can you show me i have a weight
afterwards maybe really absolutely
absolutely or you can send me a video
whatever you want seven surgeries
seven surgeries yeah um fusions this is
you have an accident
i played hockey in sports my whole life
and uh
yeah but uh you know how it's
embarrassing because i think it happened
in a grocery store i was working at a
grocery store
and we used to throw boxes off the truck
in the morning yeah
and i remember them throwing a big box
of hard canned peas
hard canned peas hard canned just a can
of peas
yeah boxes and i remember go whoa that's
weird
you caught it or you caught it but i
something shifted in my back
well that's probably all but it's not
the grocery store
it was a culmination of the things that
led up to
you catching that at the grocery store
hockey grocery store
yes straps dysfunction all these things
just added up
and then there was the moment where you
caught the very heavy
canned pea box yeah pass the peas
what year was that that was 19. how old
were you it was 198
90 89 okay and so i had my first surgery
and i was 18.
wow yeah so i've had the elbows since
and they said it was a slip disc a bulge
disc bulging disc i had
pain shooting down my leg shooting the
doctor says he needs
immediate surgery he's gonna lose
feeling in his leg and so i had
ended up having the surgery so yeah i
don't have that kind of pain anymore but
it just
overt stiffness doing clean and jerks
when i played football
thank you yeah this guy this guy
was a not a good football player well
you are a walk-on
yes so which yeah which puts you in a
category of
uh you know uh cannon fodder
so you are you are used to make the
starters
better so abused uh yeah in the most
sort of like
yes i would love to get out there and be
abused by these division one
all american athletes because i want to
yeah so right
it was fun as hell i loved it but uh but
the i would they made us do cleaning
jerks and i pulled
all my the muscles in my lower back and
pain shooting down my
all that stuff couldn't move couldn't
drive and the
weight coach was just like come back in
three days don't move
and then it got better and so wow so far
two people who've told you to do
something you listened and it worked and
it worked
usually it's like oh i know this guy
he'll fix you yeah no none of them were
yeah but again that it's not a safe
sport
how big were you you're like 245 pounds
six foot
four as a walk-on i got to almost 250
pounds i think i walked on at about 220
pounds
and i just ate and lifted weights and
ran
those were the dicks and you could catch
a ball are you still you're you're very
athletic i was good at catching the ball
but nothing compared to the starters
i was i i was i uh a
just a that was a dream they were so
much better than me
uh mark bruner and ernie conwell they
went to the nfl
and stayed many years and played in
numerous super bowls did they ever
invite you to come to a game
absolutely not no uh i've kept in
minor contact over with them but it
wasn't a thing where we
like remained right close friends it was
it was uh yeah those guys uh ernie
conwell at the age of 21 was benching
520 pounds oh my god and he
was cleaning and jerking a 365.
didn't sound right it just doesn't sound
right he's cleaning and jerking
just he has three 365 pounds of pressure
jerking and cleaning he also could run
the 40 yard dash in 4.5 seconds
and that is cruising at 300
he was almost 300 pounds jesus hey do
you
this is back to the community days you
did that six years we did it for six
years we were canceled
twice but yes we did it for six years
because the people the fans brought it
back in a way they hit
is that true well yeah because well when
we were canceled the first time
uh we went to yahoo because yahoo
somehow did some analytics that
that the show was critically acclaimed
and popular enough for them to try their
streaming service which
they then blamed us on paul feig for
shutting it down which was
unfair but i like to tell people i shut
down an entire streaming service
that seems like something pretty cool
yeah uh and
your iq must be off the charts let me
tell you about it um
my iq was off the charts for when i did
the movie i'm trying to think of a
sharon stone movie that
uh when i did a sat no uh what was the
one she did with stallone
uh the the the not the good fellows but
the
cantina the the cantina guys no not the
cantina guys
the uh what's what is like a bomber they
were like setting up no no
that was assassins oh antonio banderas
that was shot in seattle i remember that
uh camelot now what is it it starts with
a c
doesn't it this is where the producer
wait is it is it not cliffhanger
no it's sharon stone and who stallone
stallone oh no i was wrong it was way
off they had that shower scene that
everyone was like they have a shower
what are you doing you notice you're
crossing your legs right now what i did
yeah yeah i can't do it you cross your
legs i think we should use that shot
i didn't notice did i do that was i
wearing underwear because as you know
during rehearsal i do not wear underwear
but when i shoot
i wear underwear that's the thing that's
my thing oh
god and thank god i got rid of these
benign growths
oh my gosh look at that i was gonna jump
on that but you did
you did good grab good catch something
you probably don't talk specialist
the special specialist i think it's the
camera
inside of you is brought to you by
better help better help
online therapy they've been a sponsor
for quite a long time i think it's
because it's working
i think as people start to believe that
um
therapy works and i think that's why
it's working that's why they've been a
sponsor for a while because i think you
know even ryan here
got with better help and how you doing
they're doing doing all right so far
you kind of dig it right yeah it's kind
of nice to talk to someone other than
your girlfriend or your best friend
that they could be you know somebody
could be objective who's a professional
it is nice to have an objective
third party uh to talk to that's great
say uh look as we begin to see the light
at the end of the
covet tunnel a lot of people are still
feeling down um
and emotionally out of sorts you may not
feel depressed or at a total loss but if
you're feeling a little bit off or your
relationships are suffering
it could be a sign you should talk to
somebody online therapy can help
a better help is pretty simple if you
want to get help all you do is fill out
a questionnaire to help
better help assess your needs and match
you with a professional
licensed therapist so many people have
asked me does this stuff really work
the answer is yes it's just uh i i don't
even hesitate
um it's something i've been doing for a
long time
um being able to talk to someone just
you start out your day better i like to
do in the morning
some people like to do it at night at
the end of a stressful day
i i particularly like the morning so
it's kind of like you're tired you're
fatigued you're already stressed you're
already
upset about something and you get
everything out of your system and you
start your day
but to each his own once you fill out
the questionnaire you start
communicating with your therapist in
under 48 hours
schedule secure weekly video phone or
even live
chat appointments the therapists have a
broad range of expertise that may not be
locally available in your area
log into your account anytime to send a
message to your therapist
betterhelp is committed to great matches
so it's easy and free to change
therapists if needed yeah and it's more
convenient it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and financial aid
is available let me tell you something
i've done
in person and those are astronomically
high they charge you an arm a leg and a
couple other things
and better help is certainly fair the
price is to me astonishing how low it is
our listeners today get 10 off their
first month to betterhelp.com
inside that's better h-e-l-p-com
slash inside for 10 off their first
month
inside of you is brought to you by geico
geico makes it easy i'll tell you what
they do make it easy
they make it easy on me they make my
life easy all you do is geico.com and
you get a quote
and you know if you got homeowners
insurance
renters insurance auto policies how
about paying
all of it on one thing geico that's what
they do
they make it simple for you and we've
got a lot going on it's hard to pay our
rent it's hard to pay our our mortgage
it's always the hardest thing to do
and what makes it easy is geico they
make it easy
for you to bundle your homeowners or
renters insurance along with your auto
policy we've just got so much going on
around our houses ryan
our apartments we've got we don't have
time for this just guys
go to geico.com get a quote and see how
much
you could save it's geico easy visit
geico.com today
even a rosenbaum can do it inside of you
is brought to you by
paint your life look this is a unique
thing right here ryan if you want to
give a truly meaningful gift
you've got to try paintyourlife.com get
a professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo
at a truly affordable price choose from
a team of world-class artists and work
with them until every detail
is perfect user-friendly platform lets
you order a custom made hand painted
portrait in less than five minutes
quick and easy process get a
hand-painted portrait in about
three weeks this is really unique i mean
when you get something for like a friend
or a birthday gift or whatever
and you it shows that you put the work
in but you really didn't
you know somebody else is doing this for
you but you're kind of guiding them you
feel like the director
so it's kind of a cool thing it's a
really cool thing and
i think it makes you for a unique gift
for anniversaries birthdays
um all that stuff meaningful personal
and can be cherished forever at
painterlife.com there's no risk
if you don't love the final painting
your money is refunded
guaranteed and right now as a limited
time offer
get 20 percent off your painting that's
right
20 off and free shipping to get this
special offer
text the word inside to 64 000.
that's inside to 64 640
text inside to 64 000 paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
terms apply available at
paintyourlife.com
terms now look this is probably
something you don't talk about you
probably are just like i'm not going to
talk about it but maybe you do talk
about it but i should just say it
chevy chase yeah yeah i talk about it
all the time you do i i never heard you
talk about but you know
he's someone i loved i grew up with i
was like this is my favorite i used
people you see kind of look like him if
you if
chevy and barbara eden had a baby and i
was like cool
i like him yeah um i met him once he was
cool
uh and then when i heard all this stuff
i kind of got like oh
[ __ ] man was he just a bastard on set
that he just hated
and like there's a lot of thoughts that
go because you read all the stuff that
people say and you re you know hear the
the media chatting about it and then my
theory was
that in his world he was like
i'm a movie star i've been a movie star
for a long time
and now i'm a guy who kind of comes up
and says a funny line and does whatever
and this isn't good enough for me
and uh i don't like being here but
that's just my theory
but i don't know what happened so anyway
well i think um
there was probably exactly what you just
said uh
i uh he was someone that did not want to
be there for the hours that we were
keeping
and the hours were long there was no
doubt about that and uh and
the hours were the hours because we were
shooting a movie every week it wasn't
it wasn't uh you know documentary style
uh or anything like that except for one
episode
uh and so he didn't like that
and um there was no doubt and i think he
would absolutely agree
he sometimes could be in not great moods
and um and that did so
he would have to be kind of shot out you
know we have to get him
uh you know we have to get him off out
of out for the day
because he didn't want to be there that
long and
so that that was a big problem was that
incredibly frustrating as the lead on
the show did you ever have to have a
conversation
did they ask you to talk to him oh i
would tease i would go
i'm literally missing my children
growing up right now
uh but that's fine and um yeah i mean we
would we he was so funny on the show
when you look at what was on camera it's
super funny it's really good uh
but he was always uh he definitely did
not want to be there
those hours and i think there was some
of the
he was a big huge obviously the biggest
comedy star of the 80s or he was had the
highest paid at least
but between vacation and fletch and you
know the
zillion other movies he did caddyshack
and all that
it yeah i'm sure there was some of that
but i know he was being
well compensated for it right that said
you get someone like alec baldwin who
did 30 rock who was in a
you know big huge movie star for a long
time and then
you know reinvented himself through that
show
um but you know it was unfortunate then
chevy was you know
he left the show under uh quite
crazy circumstances so um
it uh was yeah it was definitely
it it could be tough some days other
days he was great did it sever the
relationship with the other actors
is there anybody who has a relationship
with him who has checked in with him who
still sort of like hey you know you
didn't like being on the show you
retired you're older you
whatever it is or or is it kind of
severed i don't know
i still have i called him a few years
ago when i played him in a movie
uh i was so jealous of that because i
thought i should play him oh
i was so jealous of you i really was
like oh my god joel's so
lucky well i was the right height so
yeah i'm not that tall i'm only six feet
thanks for bringing that up
so yeah uh well you're back you would be
much taller but chevy had a bad back
he did have a bad battery uh another
reason why i thought i should play him
oh interesting i'm kidding so go ahead
and just called him i called him to tell
him that i was gonna play him you know
like there's this movie
gonna be made and i'm gonna be in and
i'm gonna be playing you
and but he was happy that doug kenny was
getting his
uh finally his due uh which because doug
kenny really is kind of like the
hamilton of
70s comedy as far as you know like with
creating national lampoon and and then
of course
writing the animal house and and making
caddyshack and then dying very young uh
but uh uh you know i then i call so then
i called him when the movie was made i
was like the movie's coming out now
so uh what did he answer the phone he
talked to you he was
he did it i mean i would text him to let
him know i was gonna call him uh but
uh he seemed fine with it and you know
but we haven't
spoken i don't know if anybody in the
cast has spoken to him in a few years
right i mean it's been a while but
initially i saw his wife who is
lovely right uh uh but you know
it it it was definitely contentious but
there were i mean if you watch him on
the show he's super
super funny i had i i wrote a treatment
for
a vacation sequel oh because they were
back when they were looking for one they
uh they obviously made it and they
didn't choose us but i remember i had
him and bev sort of attached that was
really on and chevy was on and they
liked it they loved the idea so my
writing partner at the time chris
mcdonald we pitched it to new line
and they said great pitch we
we've loved this pitch and i thought
this is a great [ __ ] idea this is the
last hurrah everybody goes on this trip
together
and they were just like yeah we don't
want um
chevy and bev to be as prominent in the
show
it's too much of them we want them you
know wow they're very little
and what was that response to that well
i guess this i could switch up the pitch
you know but that it was part of like
they go on this one last family trip
together
and you know chevy hands the keys off to
uh that sounds great
it was great and they just go and you
get the mother from uh the woman from uh
everybody loves raymond yeah she was
still alive at the time oh the mob yes
the mom and a couple of the other
characters and kind of i want i missed
like
christmas vacation the family all
together and that's what people could
relate to so i wanted one last hurrah
and it was i really loved the pitch and
we were a little we were we were sad
because we worked really hard on it but
they went in a different direction and
that's just
the price you pay is there a world where
you could make that movie with just
people that are not uh associated at all
i know at the sure but i guess you could
why not just do a a great vape family
vacation
and make that movie where he the dad
just says hey
yeah uh not russ but roy yeah i'm
handing the keys to you this is our last
year after this this is our last trip
and then or
why don't you play the dad i'll play
randy quade wait why do i have to play
the dad do you think i'm old
well i don't know about that i don't
think people believe me as a dad yeah do
i look like a dad yet
no like grandpa dad you're right there
yeah this guy's like this [ __ ] yeah well
you look like ryan's dad
no offense uh but uh oh
girl why not just make that movie right
go ahead ma i mean i think right here
let's let's pitch it out do you think
people want to hear this
yes no okay i don't think we should do
it i tried
i don't know i don't think these people
work anymore and i just got sold but
i wanted to remake the movie motel hell
oh my god it's one of my favorites
it's an amazing movie what a great
concept it's such
a great movie guys it's such a dark
beautiful old school
horror film that was one of the first
movies my mom rented and made me watch
with her when i was eight
oh my gosh yeah i know that's why i'm
[ __ ] up yeah we would
sneak down into my friend jason cusack's
basement like for his second birthday
and like
they had show time and there was my mom
would be like do not
watch motel hell we know it's on i don't
know why they just didn't
disconnect disconnected but of course we
were like she's gone motel hell
and for those of you who have not heard
of it or seen it it is worth it
there's a few certainly it's so fun and
then so i was like
like to re my friend scott derrickson
and i who did doctor strange and he did
actually did um
uh ghost cops as my friend calls um
delivers from evil but
uh we were like we want to make it and
they're like yeah
no i love like i was like what
we could just here's we could just get
we'll get you money
like this will get you money and like
man now are you a big horror fan
uh i i'm not a per i'm not like you and
that i have this
i really enjoy them me too good ones
there's a lot of bad ones
there's many many people a lot of bad
ones but boy the good ones are
great yeah like it follows was a great
great little horror movie
great idea yeah yeah well i've written
two and i'm
we're just going out with them now
because i'm a big fan i just love horror
i just i
and i complain a lot because you know
explain rotten tomatoes to me because
i know it's supposed to be like well
it's all these reviews that add up to
get the mean of the you know the average
right of score and i go i don't believe
it i don't believe that someone gave
this an 87
there's no [ __ ] way and it happens
all the
time do they does the studio higher like
is good right and the movie's not that
good so when i watch the movie and it's
like this is a 40 at best and i'm
maybe a 50 but 87 percent
so can you name names on a movie that
you're like this is not an 87 percenter
you don't have to i don't want to put
you on the spot i want to do that
i just watched a movie called uh you
know like i hate to bomb
no maybe don't but you don't you know
it's called something okay
so that sounds good and i love that
movie
yeah and i gave it a 99. so uh well
i feel like that happens a lot where
i was like oh that's not as that's not
as good as that
just does but it is interesting when the
reviews are like 40 and then the
you know then the people look at the
audience yeah always
always look at the audience the audience
are saying three out of five and the
reviewers are saying 90 percent listen
to your fellow
yellow people that's why roger ebert was
such a great reviewer because he would
be like
and you'd see him he's like okay it's
not the greatest movie but boy did i
enjoy it
yeah be like there's some really great
stuff and here's why it works so well
but it's not the great it's not going to
change your life it's not important
but it's sure as hell fun have you ever
had bad reviews
like really bad i was nominated for a
razzy for the happy time murders
and which i took as a compliment you
should
but that movie got universally destroyed
and i think it became one of those that
people enjoyed
destroying so you know once that catches
on
even though you know wasn't as like
there's movies i've been in that have
bombed
way bigger uh but nobody they weren't
even
a blip and people were like oh well it's
just a thing but they
uh boy i'm trying to think of like a
movie where
oh when i got community the review
said of the pilot said
this show is really great it's got
everything you need
but it's never going to work because of
the lead
and that was just oh
i've had [ __ ] like that i had something
where i won't name the movie because the
other actor in the movie
is a good friend of ours and would not
like me mentioning this
but the review was the movie like they
hated the movie they go
so and so is not funny so and so
will never be funny and michael
rosenbaum has never
been funny and i was just what the [ __ ]
and of course you start going didn't you
see that but i wanted to call the
reviewer
that is not a review when you think
about it i mean that is
that is not a review of a movie that is
just insults right the guy just wanted
to kill us
he just wanted to be like hey what do
you think of that reviewers do you guys
do you guys like that critic and you're
like you seen how he dresses
and be like no he dresses like an idiot
i was like
but what did he think of event horizon
uh well yeah his mustache is stupid
so when i see stuff like that or when
reviewers go like
well here we go again with this thing
where this guy does this thing and i was
like wait
so you don't like the movie because the
person in it did something you didn't
like
right so what are we talking about
exactly you don't like these people
for some reason you have something
against them so you're never gonna like
this movie
yeah it's like that you can feel the
glee when they get to take things apart
and i under you know like i hosted the
soup where i
enjoyed making yeah making fun of
bachelor in paradise because they were
barefoot and having sex and they were
high and they
fell out of the bed and then they're
boob you know like whatever it was it
was like that seems
but when you go like that then when you
see these guys you can see them enjoying
it right then i'm like all right well
you know
back to the soup you had to take over
for john henson
no well he left he left and then uh
aisha tyler came in
tyler came in and then it was uh and
that had been on for ten years
i always think of it as john henson and
then you that's how i remember no i used
it for two years
and at that point it had already like
talk shows were already waning at that
point
so in 2004 it was not even called the
soup
we it started out being called the what
the blank
awards which was a very confusing title
and when the new boss came in ted
harbert he was like i don't understand
what that did someone
forget it it was supposed to be like the
what the hell award the what the [ __ ]
awards what the heck awards and
so he was just like don't we have that
talk soup name and then that
became that and you're asked to do how
often do you turn [ __ ] down
because honestly and you could be humble
you're gonna be humble about this
but i know that you probably get offers
to to for tons of [ __ ] especially to
host everything because you're so
likable personable people want to live
yeah but right so you get a lot of
offers to do so not as much as you'd
think
well i mean you got the the joel mchale
show
as much as i would like oh yeah yeah
that was sharks you did the soup you got
i mean you're kind of a crime scene
kitchen kitchen
everybody crime scene kitchen on now
someone's bleeding out
someone's bleeding fasting it looks
funny uh it's
just like you have a good time you have
a good rapport with the people and
you're just like they're
very intense bakers and of course that's
my opportunity it's
funny enough you were we were talking
about what people wear the reviewer but
i remember in one clip you were
looking at some guy and he's like he's
like i'm going to keep her asking you
about your turtleneck and he's
the woman goes well look at you're
wearing yes but i'm the host right
yeah so it's very you know she was
dressed like she was hunting foxes in
and he was wearing a wool turtleneck
they're both brilliant bakers but i was
like dude and he could see the sweat
like around the seams and i was like
enjoy
baking in here and uh in your i don't
know your ski chalet with all the
windows open but it's
not oh god uh happily happily yeah
happily
i have to see that uh good times
of course i know him ben david i've
known him for years and i'm going to i'm
going to watch this film
uh yeah carrie beche is one of the best
actors i've ever worked with
and she's i don't know why she's not a
gigantic movie star
uh and then the rest of the cast is just
was it a fun time
great fun was it hard it wasn't that i
mean no it was a
ben ran a really tight set and the
director of photography is a genius and
so everything was pretty well put
together
you know it's a very tiny little movie
but it was
really fun to make and the only thing
the only real hiccup was
one of the sewage pipes burst in this
super modern
mansion we were shooting in and the
sewage flowed out all over the carpets
and did it smell like [ __ ] for the
remainder of the shoot it was pretty
rough
it was when you're doing a party scene
and you're trying to eat
and then all you're doing is smelling
waste
it's do you think chevy would have
wanted to go home uh well
i don't know you all wanted to go home
when that time there was [ __ ]
a lot of like can we keep the windows
open during but then they dried it out
and i don't know how
we were walking around barefoot because
we're all it was like a pool scene so
oh god yeah amputee i was amputated so
it was bad
i got to see this flesh aiding i want to
see you amputated uh yeah let me know
what you think
yeah i love horror i watch it all the
time and i'm always it's not
happily it's not no you just said you
got your leg cut off no from
walking in the sewage yeah it was a joke
yes oh
yes i didn't get it i mean i didn't i
wasn't smart enough to receive
or i didn't deliver it i think you
delivered it perfectly because i think
you laughed
yeah no i got it thank you jesus thank
you josh hartnett's brother
it kind of does right that's a comment
you're a handsome guy hey
i gotta ask this your body's so tight
we've talked about this your body
yeah i i know you look you look really
great it's really just desperation but
you've been midlife crisis but you fast
right you do this fasting thing i hear i
used to do a lot of did that work
it worked for a long time and then it
kind of started not working because i
think
i put my metabolism into a state where
every time i would get
eat a lot then it would be like thank
you for this we're going to keep this as
long as we possibly can
and so you get bloated and things i just
noticed that
when i would have a meal i was like oh
i'm not kind of maintaining the weight i
want to
be at this is getting very specific guys
but now i find that
small meals and just really portion
control more
more than anything is that's my problem
i try to eat big meals like three times
three times a day but you should have
smaller meals like four or five small
meals a day
i really only like dinner is the real
meal that i have so
this morning i've had a handful of nuts
and something yeah are you dying right
now blueberries no i'm so used to that
that i mean i'm sure i've had like five
cups of coffee nice mug by the way
uh to which are you referring it's an
inside of you mug you can get on the
inside of your online store what do they
retail for i don't know like 17 bucks
but right mug but right now on sale for
11.99
and just swipe up swipe up don't swipe
don't swipe
i'm not in control of that and then
you'll you know what else i feel good
about
11.99 for just the smallest flavored
water
is hint you know what they don't give me
any money but i love them and they send
me tons of water and i really like their
water hints really good delicious
uh i can i say uh this is a pretty
important statement
that one people oh shoot that when
people like like you like hint
right yeah i do it's great it's very
tasty yeah and then people are like he's
getting paid for that
but they really just send you a bunch of
a few boxes i don't get paid at all they
just send me when i need water
that hap i feel like that happens a lot
with celebrities uh
who or ha people that have a presence on
um social media they're like
he's getting paid for that and uh and
then sometimes they do
but and that's pretty obvious but a lot
of times it's like no i just i just
really like a yeti mug
i just i just really i went out and
spent 30 bucks on it so
wait a minute so you really are you are
you saying you believe
that they're just they just like the
product what are you saying here because
it sounds like you're saying
yeah this yeti mug that i'm using i just
i am going to go look for those
like sometimes like i'll post a photo or
something like oh yeah okay i see
nice lands end sweater well
uh so i get a couple thousand dollars
yeah that was that sweater
definitely the land's end but thank you
for the hint i will definitely drink it
soon inside of you is brought to you by
helix helix sleep i don't know about you
but there's nothing more important to me
than sleep ryan
there's nothing more important and i'm
telling you with all my surgeries and
all the [ __ ] that i've dealt with and
i'll say [ __ ] on this air
on the air [ __ ] on this hair i'll tell
ya because you know people sleep in a
lot of bad beds and they wake up and
they feel like crap the whole day and
if you don't get a good night's sleep
the rest of your day is ruined you're
tired
you're cramped and i know what that's
like and that's why i love the new helix
sleep bed
uh they are just they're they're
comfortable as hell for me
it makes sense um i don't find many beds
that make me feel
comfortable i'm always squirming around
trying to get comfortable
so helixly has a quiz that you take it's
just two minutes even i passed it it's
it's nothing it's just it tells you
you know it talks about your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
so it's it's one of those good things
you're doing something good for your
body
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know
will be perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have
soft medium and firm mattresses i got
the medium oh how nice
mattress is great for cooling you down
if you sleep hot and even a helix plus
mattress for plus size
sleepers yeah i took the the helix quiz
and i got i matched to a medium
which which which is nice it's right
there in the middle it's like porridge
you know what i mean ryan it's a
goldilocks yeah it's been so awesome
getting messages from so many of you who
also found the helix mattress of your
dreams
and uh it makes me feel good i just want
everybody to sleep
well comfortably wake up refreshed
lord knows it's the one thing we need in
this world just go to helixsleep.com
inside take their two-minute quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk-free
i don't know why you wouldn't do that
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it
but you will helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
inside that's pretty incredible that's
inside for up to two hundred dollars off
and two
free pillows helix sleep inside of you
is brought to you by
nitsa it's a fact that a child's body
temperature rises three to five times
faster than adults
and leaving a child in a hot vehicle can
lead to their death very
quickly sadly in 2020 24 children died
of pediatric vehicular heat stroke
and many of these incidents occurred
when parents or caregivers simply forgot
the child
was in the car unintentionally leaving a
child in the car is a tragedy that could
happen to anyone
please set yourself reminders on your
cell phone or place something you'll
need in the back seat to help you
remember
that your child is still in the car if
your partner or caregiver is taking your
child to daycare
check with them or the child care staff
to make sure that the child was dropped
off
and when you've arrived at your
destination always check to make sure
the car is empty heat stroke deaths are
preventable when adults take the proper
precautions
be safe and always look for your baby
before you lock
paid for by nitsa you know briefly i
just want to talk about like you found
out you were dyslexic after your
your your kids yeah after my first kid
was diagnosed
which it was one of those things i
probably
should have noticed earlier but how do
you notice it what are this because now
that you know you could probably
tell the world the symptoms so that they
can kind of look out for them if you
read
very slowly and you can't spell [ __ ]
that's a pretty good sign
well [ __ ] and when you look at words
you're like
okay and people like they're backwards i
was like ah they don't really look like
anything
and uh and when you say things backwards
no people are like oh they're backwards
it's like it's not backwards okay it's
just kind of like
uh jumping out yeah it's just uh doesn't
look right and uh
so you read very slowly and uh and i
think at that time when i was a kid
it you would you did not tell people you
like i don't think i'm
so you i like literally i was tested and
they're like he seems smart
but um he's what we call a slow starter
and they so and then i told the doctor
that who diagnosed my
first kid and she was like put her head
down there like they told the second
grader he was slow
i was like ah yeah that was not probably
yeah and the
the you don't think about that stuff but
like when spelling bee days would come
up
people would start doing like slow claps
for me before i even started
talking because they were like spell
thorough i'm
like here we go and uh so
i never knew that i said this day that's
a tough word thorough
yeah i always thought if you were trying
to learn english and they're like here's
thorough
though and through they mean all
different things yeah so good luck i
would say like
you know how you get to ask somebody
like is that a noun is that a
i'd say thorough is that a a person an
artist
um henry george henry david
thoreau thoreau
george thorough good good bad
yeah but now but you but dyslexic people
they never lose it but you
definitely find ways to uh accommodate
so so believe me when the soup started
and they were like okay here's a
half an hour of jokes um on a
teleprompter i'd be like
how often do you mess up so uh
it took me four hours to get through 22
minutes of jokes if you take a cut out
of the commercials
i bet it'll take me that long too
forever so but by the time once i got
into it the anxiety went down
which i had a ton of because i'm not a
little bit [ __ ] this up and i
would like show the clip and i'd be like
i'm doing well and then uh and so
uh i got so then we started doing the
show live
so i began you i began like hey guys
i've got dyslexia i don't know how this
is going to go so i started using it as
a promo
right right and only one time did they
have to
i screwed up and i was like ah [ __ ] and
then all their eyes were bright and like
uh and they hit the button
and i was like oh i said [ __ ] and then
like hit the button again
so [ __ ] it became sort of fun
and i became i was like i'm just gonna
you this is the way i'm gonna use it and
i always looked at david letterman as
the
king of if he didn't like a punchline
he would point it out and say it for the
rest of the show
and so then when that had started i was
like oh just do that
because then if i screwed something up
i'm like remember that punch line i
missed oh that would have been great
people to love that
that would have been a great moment for
people at home to enjoy anyway
so that's how i adapted with it
and so to this day i don't read books i
just listen
i mean thank god for audible it's it's
the yeah
it's it has changed my life because it's
all i do now i don't even listen to
music as much as i used to because i
just i you just lie there and just
listen to a great story
when i work out that's when i do it
really you listen when you work out i
listen to books when i work out don't
you need something
well maybe you should listen to a
reading of like the fugitive so you have
the energy i mean
well i do i did listen to a l i do
listen to a lot of jack reacher
uh when i uh because those books are
written so well and they move
along so well that right uh but
sometimes i like
i decided i'd go back and try to listen
to a lot of the classics so
so once you get pretty knee-deep in
dostoyevsky
and you're trying to keep track of all
the names
and then all their nicknames i had to i
literally would write it i was like i
had to keep a list i was like okay
this is misha who has a nickname uh and
so
yeah that one that was you know we do a
segment in the beginning which we just
started
uh it's it's we didn't do this yet but
just it's quick it's
it's a mental health check-in it's
called just how you doing how you
doing and really just it's just how
your mental health is now how you're
feeling you know whether your anxiety
what you do for your anxiety
what you're feeling now right now or
this last week or like lately
uh pretty good uh i am
i i like to think that i i'm like hey
things are going
fine and well what problems do you have
what don't complain what do you have to
complain about
uh but then i you know when i wake up at
four in the morning in a panic
i'm like what are you panicking i think
uh what's gonna happen
what's gonna happen with the rest of
everything and a lot of that a lot of
like am i ever gonna work again
uh are my kids gonna be okay how's my
wife doing
a lot of that and um
so that's not fun well what helps that
you like
for ambien and a shot of vodka and then
i can sleep for a perfect
hour you liar no uh what helps talking
to my wife
uh i should probably go to therapy right
which i i don't but i
should and um yeah it's like it's funny
i just read a ryan reynolds quote
of all uh and he was just like yeah i
he's the same
he he basically said exactly why he was
like i never
turn anything down because i live in a
constant state of anxiousness and i was
like
yeah that's me uh that's perfectly
perfectly described
and uh i am running i am on a
i'm on a gerbils wheel all the time
because when i first got here
when it started i mean because i was so
you know that moment you're like i just
want to work i just want to work and
then
oh yeah and there's that flip where i'm
like oh my gosh i'm working it's
happening
and it doesn't necessarily uh scratch
the
itch but uh but that attitude of
hustler like being an actor you're
always hustling
you're that's the nature and i think
sometimes that's very healthy and
other times it just keeps the um
pistons going the whole time and then
when you go on vacation you have a panic
attack so
uh that train i have not really learned
how to get off of
i and i think you're like me in that i
truly love working i love it i cannot
believe
people pay me to do what i love but that
is separate than
the uh you know then just like keep the
keep the plate spinning all the time
right i yeah i i hear that i
for me i you know the more i work
i i just envelop myself and things so
much that i
i'm so hard on myself that i work extra
hard and i spend way more time
learning lines getting in the care
whatever it is
that it's kind of hell it's not really
fun
it's not fun when you're there doing it
is it fun i'm there
doing it um yeah it is fun because i
like people and i like crews and i like
that kind of thing and if it's a fun
role it's always good you know some
people i don't care i just like to work
i'll do anything and i go i'm not
i can't do that i have to really i have
to really just love what i'm
it's not just about love what you're
doing but love what you're saying love
the people you're working with it's a
bunch it's a
combination of a lot of things i agree
so but that's a lucky thing it's lucky
enough thing to work but lucky enough to
be on something that's good
that's extra lucky yeah it's rare i
think people yes
it's it's so rare when you're on
something really good
and rare when that good
lines up with a bunch of people that
want to see it yeah yeah
it's very and i can i was like oh that's
that's uh what even seinfeld said
they're like are you gonna do another
version of seinfeld and he was he said
something like it's really hard to hit
four grand slams in yankee stadium again
and i was like damn that's a good
analogy
perfect perfectly he threaded all the
needles with
what an extraordinary show yeah
extraordinary characters
and it was you just universally love
i think it's the same thing on a
different level i mean obviously the
community or smallville weren't as big
as
seinfeld nothing is but on the same
level what have you done since community
if that was that or what is guns in
smallville i'm like
i can only really go down for the most
part i can only go
downhill i've tried about a million
things yeah i mean it's
for me to get better than that that's i
mean that was a huge show community was
a huge show so
funny because the whole time we were
like i think that's it yes
you know we were told numerous times at
the end of seasons they were like
hey can this last episode be the season
and
series finale like that's how like
just the confidence like the like the
network just going like
well we'll see we might have something
better
and uh unbelievable oh yeah you all
loved it you wanted to be there
we all knew we the hours were bananas
but we all knew because we would do
these table reads which were
uh so great and then i would stand up
and point
at the like the sony and the nbc
executives and i was like
do not change a word and then i'd walk
out
and and they were like hey you're like a
bully i'm like yeah i'm this
[ __ ] yes don't do it don't change
anything
and uh so yeah and they didn't you seem
like a guy that doesn't uh
really when you get mad everybody goes
oh there's a reason because you don't
seem like you get mad very often if you
lose your [ __ ]
joel's upset something's something's
real
right i am amazing at blowing up
at inanimate objects like that right
there that
mask of if the mask was not staying up
on that thing
i might destroy it you might kill jason
voorhees
yesterday i was logging into a computer
i hadn't logged into
and i so i had you know you had to get
the code from your like
log into gmail and it said do you uh and
you put in and i accidentally hit
reset password and the zoom call had
started four minutes earlier
and i screamed god damn it and my wife
came in
and she's like where's the emergency
and then you know when i explain it it's
i sound like an insane person
like well i accidentally pushed reset
password
this that merited me screaming and
uh she just rolled her eyes yeah she
said uh-huh okay
well i'm gonna go uh you know deal with
the education of our children
so i'm gonna calm the kids down yeah i'm
gonna go take care of real life problems
so
uh hey really quick and then we're done
we just there's some [ __ ] talking rapid
fire questions
from fans from patreon i love my patrons
go to patreon.com
inside of you but do you think they'll
ever be a community reunion
because they're doing all these other
shows uh if you had asked me that
a year ago i would have said yes but no
and i would have said like man who knows
but we did a table read a year ago and
it was so much fun
and donald came so it was great and
uh pedro pascal played this part in the
in a table read and i like i burst out
crying
with my wife afterwards because i was
just like i missed all those people
so much i mean just crying and i was i
couldn't keep it in
and uh so i think now
more than ever it's possible uh but
as you know uh you need like millions of
dollars
you need schedules to line up you need
scripts
i think you need the head of the whole
operation to go i just love that show
yeah maybe right you need you need you
like if you're building an aircraft
carrier
there's a lot of parts that go in and
yeah you need an admiral to go like
let's make it
and uh so i would say
it's it's more likely now than it was
it's more likely well than it was a year
ago okay but
all right uh but i uh you know again
if someone out there has a like i don't
know
40 million dollars guys come on you want
to see a community reunion 40 mil
that's what the mugs are seven 99.
there's a couple of hedge fund guys
listening right
i'm sure they must be all right this is
rapid fire with joe mchale she's called
[ __ ] talking with joel mchale fast
answers here we go rapid nico p i had
the pleasure of watching you perform at
theater
sports here in seattle on monday a
weekend how did that help you in your
career go hawks
go hawks go hawks go hawks um i think
the sheer number of hours of stage time
really helped being on stage four nights
a week for years and just being out
there
really helped me a lot and of course
being there with a group of incredible
improvisers michelle k best prank that
happened on the community set
uh donald would try to pull my pants
down all the time
could do it now though could he uh cause
that [ __ ] would have
you know that would fly years ago i
would try that stuff
all right well you know i was my guy
friends i did give him permission
oh oh okay you can do it before i don't
want to know about it just surprised me
no there was never like a there wasn't
like
like it wasn't like a prank where like
we all spent you know like
i was like i did it i i stuffed their
trailer full of cotton balls that never
there was any nothing
right right right so the pants that's
funny i like the pants yes yes
sarah f what was the funniest thing you
saw while hosting crime scene kitchen
i think the disastrous desserts there's
a couple that are coming up
that are pretty amazing did it just make
you genuinely laugh oh laugh
so hard there and like there's i can't
uh
yeah there i we ate raw eggs on this
last one where i'm like hey let's hope
we're not sick steph a are you and ken
planning on returning to the darkest
timeline podcast
ken is the busiest person on the planet
and so
uh we would love to but we but soon as
august hit he started the mass singer
and i
then that ended that i did card sharks
and then so we just kept
missing so i would love to but we'll see
i love that he crashed uh your interview
with kelly clarkson that was cute that
was fun
so great yes even though i hate his guts
he's one of my best friends
and i love him so much diane r do you
have a nickname in elementary school
in uh high school i was just called the
[ __ ] no
uh astral yeah no my friend adam
satesmith would call me mcmailman
uh but that was about it no really no i
didn't michael
mckay well because i would have called
you michael yeah
oh yeah you never heard that one that's
too easy mccabe it was because
carl malone who was on the utah
championship and i played basketball so
they called me mcmail man
even though i rode the bench most of the
time seems like you wrote the bench in
college and football i was on a
very good basketball team wow yeah but
uh i got in sometimes you got in you
scored our guard was yeah he was
like six or seven lisa h final question
what was it like playing star man
on star girl and did you enjoy putting
on the tights
absolutely when the two people would
come into my trailer to help me get into
that thing
i felt like a superhero be like there's
a crime happening
let me get two people to help me get
into this thing for 40 minutes
uh yeah it's so much fun on star girl
and i a lot of my scenes are with luke
wilson oh man
i know he is responsible from like some
of the biggest laughs i've ever had in
in movies like
that scene in royal tenenbaums and when
he's playing tennis i
couldn't control myself i had to like
just i couldn't breathe
it was so funny so the fact that i've
gotten to know him
a little bit i'm just like damn this is
great and uh
brett bassinger who plays star girl is
tremendous and she's like 22 and
you know she's in every scene and she's
great and then you're doing
wilson impression uh uh let's see he
told us like
i was like i'm just gonna
get some groceries that you had
like the groceries yeah i don't know
it's fine it's like he does this thing
where he's just like
choosing that's owen i'm doing luke luke
you're doing luke yeah also
if owen and luke could talk so hey luke
you want to go over and have some like
breakfast or something
yeah i'm gonna get some groceries
well you know they have eggs here at the
breakfast place
yeah i don't want those all right i
don't know
this is terrible no one's gonna get it i
mean idiocracy
is going to be is the one of the most
under-appreciated
it really is i remember i auditioned
that and i uh was the biggest
fail of an audition i've ever had and
dax got it well and think about
to this day when dogs are all money i
mean it's
incredible what he did yeah oh yeah i
remember i went in there for mike judge
and i just pictured mike judges wanting
something so off the wall
that i remember i brought a statue of my
dog that was about this big and i
remember i just put it on his desk and i
had this big dip in
and i was just like you want me to do
that right now you know
you you want me and i thought i was like
it was so out there
that reminded me of steven rude in
office space really who by the way isn't
happily and he's a [ __ ] genius he is
a genius
but i remember i called my manager at
the time and i go
i killed it right i killed it
he goes mike was kind of scared
like a what he goes yeah he just said
didn't know
what you were doing he just was really
it was he said it was one of the most
uncomfortable things he's ever
seen and you're like i got it and i was
like so then i'm in
yeah no uh but you know you sometimes
you go for it and you just fail
see and then you tell that story and i'm
like um someday i'll audition for mike
judge
see that's that's how don't go too big
you want subtle
i love money i have tw i tweet that out
once just every once in a while i'm like
i cannot believe how funny everything's
amazing
[ __ ] funny do you ever see it ryan
yeah no it's great yeah it is it is
underappreciated that's for sure
my friend sarah roos in that who else is
in there um what's his name big muscular
racial sans is in there
and of course maya rudolph is a
who who should be given like 12 oscars
now
for what she does yeah she's uh pretty
genius
well look this has been all i mean this
it feels like i'm glad you were
comfortable first of all i don't think
you'd be comfortable sitting you'd have
been more uncomfortable i would've had i
eventually have to put my legs up like
even when i sit in movie theaters i'm
like we're gonna put my like so those
full back seats
yeah just oh they're great so this has
been comfortable for you this is great
this has been great it felt like just a
conversation with a buddy it really did
you get ones where you're just like and
now another question and they answered
it and now i have to ask them another
question we're still trying to keep this
ball in the air
it's happened we've had some that are
just a little all over the place i mean
most of them are great most of their
guests are great but there's been a
couple that i just have to
you know you ask a question they're like
yeah that was fun
yeah like holy [ __ ] uh but what did you
and i'm going down like i'm diagramming
a sentence like you know and
just right going in there like that's
when you are dancing and then i'm like
yeah and i'm like well thank you that
was great like that was a 20 minute
interview
yeah and then people are pissed because
there's five ads in 20 minutes
[Music]
you didn't say anything so many baseball
players they're like
hey you had a good game by the seventh
inning you did that and just go six how
did you think it went
it was good we're good
how do you feel like you played tonight
well it's you know it's every game is
you know important
why do they even interview these people
i wish every athlete after the game with
an exception of a few
it's the same answer what were you
thinking at that moment oh that i just
had to hit the ball
right okay and then you did but when you
hit it were you surprised that you hit
it maybe it's the interviewer maybe
they're not getting deep enough
maybe if the guy was just like i hate
that guy when he throws the ball i hate
him and i just want to hit him with a
bat so i just hit his ball as hard as i
could
all right i love you thank you for being
here thank you for having me it's so
good this is great spending time with
you
yeah it was really fun your house is
amazing and i'm not kidding thank you
i really enjoyed it i've stolen three
things
hope you enjoyed that one i know i did i
know ryan did i did
you did i did you know and when you have
to edit these things i think that you
sometimes if you if you really are
excited about it it's easy to edit when
you're excited about a guest yeah let's
say so
and when you're not enjoying a guest
it's probably not that easy
that happens not not often because you
have to edit it to make people
enjoy it and be the best the episode it
could be and not be
selfish that's the wrong word but you
know what i mean
you can't be like well i don't really
care about this one so i'm going to give
it a half ass job no i give every edit
the same
care and then it shows it shows uh if
you guys want to join patreon
the patreon wonderful family if you
don't know what patreon is it's giving
back to the podcast giving a little
extra something to the podcast
uh you join at patreon.com inside of you
i write you a message right after you
join
or soon after and uh you get things like
uh packages every couple months from me
you get notes from me
you get questions that i answer on video
there's youtube lives there's questions
you get to ask the guests there's a
bunch of different tiers
but more importantly everybody on there
has become family and a lot of
friendships have spawned
and now you said in the creepy way yeah
you you spawned last episode
spawned spawned spawn so um join patreon
patreon.com
inside of you also if you want to go to
the inside of you online store a bunch
of cool stuff there
check it out new mugs journals lex
luthor stuff smallville stuff
i think you'll get a kick out of it also
sunspin my band is playing
july 31st two shows 2 p.m and 6 p.m
get tickets you can get tickets at
sunspin.com
uh it's going to be great we haven't
played in a month or two months so this
is going to be a big concert so i hope
you enjoy it
you come to it you can get tickets at
sunspin.com or stageit.com and type in
sunspin and get tickets and join the
family because there's going to be a lot
of fun people there
um i think some people might crash the
party maybe you'll crash the party ryan
i always crash parties
uh also letting you guys know that i'm
gonna be at some conventions
coming up i mean like soon get your
tickets i'll be in houston
folks uh and that's that's coming up
that's july 17th and 18th i'll be in
houston
just go to comicpalooza.com get your
tickets i'll also be in september 4th
dragon con
lexington it's on september 9th and west
virginia mountain near comic-con
september 24th
i know a lot of you are coming i can't
wait to see you at each and every one of
them
uh you might be the only ones my lovely
patrons coming to see me
supporting me yeah well i appreciate you
guys listening and
uh i'm gonna keep doing this as long as
you keep listening spread the word write
a review
you know who you are you mean a lot to
me let's do the top patron
shout outs nancy d mary
b leah s tricia f
sarah v little lisa yukiko sorry said
that one
jill e bryan h lauren g
nico p robin s jerry w
robert uh b nice jason
w apothean sorry i said it again kristen
okay amelia oh alison l
lucas m raj c joshua
d emily s wow cj
p wow samantha m jennifer
and stacy l carly
l h [ __ ] then there's a carly
oh uh then there's a carly l carly s
yeah carly s then jen
s jamal f stop me if you know any
janelle b tabitha 272 now because
273 yes kimberly e mike
mike good old mike mike
e correct mikey mike e you'll remember
that now eldon sopremo
99 more ra
mira santiago m yes sarah
v sarah f chad
chad this is where it gets dicey yeah
chad w
leanne leanne uh p ray
h hey a first maya p
maddie s kendrick f ashley
donna e shannon d matt x
w nobody else starts with an x
that was open uh belinda and kevin v
james r chris h dave h samantha s
spider-man
chase sheila g brad oh uh
d ray h tabitha t
tom and suzanne b liliana
a michelle okay marcus
w hannah uh you're astonishing
uh anna b yeah michael myers
michael s talia m andrew t betsy
d claire m liz j laura l
chat l rochelle nathan e taylor k
marion marion meg cage nell p
trev l dan and diane r
o ajetta jetta ajetta lorraine g
veronica k
big stevie w kendall i don't know t
carol d
sandy m no sandy b sorry sandy sandy
angel m eric c rhiannon c stephen m cory
k
super sam sure emily c sherry
s coleman g david c michelle a riley j
matt w liz l jeremy c andy t cody r
chris e
sebastian k gavinator and h elliott m
john b
and brandy d those are the wonderful
patrons
who give extra every month who i adore
thank you guys
from the bottom of my heart for
continuing to give and uh you know it's
hard because every four months i have to
send a box and
i don't always have new merch and but i
think they understand i get that like
they know that i write a note and they
know that i'm giving stuff and that uh i
try
you know i could be thoughtful every
once in a while speaking of merch what
about that one they have that one
oh yeah this is the new blue the white
and white one blue inside of your mug
and it's available
and also a black and silver one too i
burned myself in the black and silver
one i put in the microwave and i
didn't know that it was like just metal
there and i touched it and it literally
burned my hand yesterday
oh so just don't put in the microwave
it's metal it's the first thing you
learn in homemake
god uh thank you guys for all the
support don't forget all the cons i'm
coming to you can rewind um
uh the patreon as we talked about
sunspin.com if you want to get a zoom
from me
um and you want to get tickets to the
show on july 31st 2 p.m and 6 p.m
it's gonna be a wonderful stage since we
haven't done it in two months and uh
thanks for the support a lot of good
news coming uh coming up um
[Music]
and i don't know what i can announce
really so that's the thing there's
there's good stuff going on but i can't
really announce things
um i'm doing a lot of writing doing a
lot of writing and creating
and uh who knows maybe ryan will be
involved in something i do
or i'll be involved in something he does
who knows you can do with this
or you can do with that you can deal
with this remember that song yeah
who's saying that black sheep who's the
black sheep what's the black
sheep that was a good song all right
from michael rosen mom here in the
hollywood hills
and uh from ryan tay is uh also in the
hollywood hills at this moment uh we
love you guys thanks for listening
uh once again i hope you're having a
fantastic week and be good to yourselves
most importantly thanks for allowing me
to be inside each and every one of you
and thanks for coming back and listening
each and every week um thank you so much
all right